hey guys it's Johanna here are you ready
for another workout challenge this time
is going to be a squat and a plank
challenge so the goal is to complete
10,000 squats and plank in 30 days all
right
[Music]
so everybody knows how to do a basic
squat and a planked but we want to mix
it up and add in different variations
all right so get your legs ready get
your entire body ready and let's get
straight into the workout so for the
first squat it's going to be prisoner
squat for each workout we want to
complete 20 repetitions all right and
the good news is we will only be doing
the entire workout once
so you're done after them after each
exercise you're done okay all right
prisoner squat stay sugar with a pot
with its host pointed forward put both
arms just by your head and now let's go
down and up okay starting nice and easy
remember to push your butt back look
forward chest up
back flat good 20 repetitions nice keep
going and ten more let's go good and the
reason why I want you to place both
hands by a head is to make sure that
you're standing upright last four more
three two and one okay let's get
straight into a plank it's going to be
plank show the tap so start in a high
plank tap left and right that is one
okay good so making sure that your hips
is in line do not dip your hip left to
right very good
right and left it's one strong plank
good keep going halfway there
nine let's count together eight seven
six good five you should also feel the
work on your upper body four three two
last one more and straight back in to a
squat okay
side squat alright so start in a narrow
position we went to squat to the left
and to the right ready let's go right
that's one and that's two good good that
wide feel the work on the outer glute
feel the work on your hips as well keep
going ten more three four good five last
five more breathe in and breathe out as
you come up and one more and it's
straight back into plank okay it's going
to be a plank rock so stuck in a low
plank position I wait to rock forward
and back alright let's go
and that's one if at all this is too
tough for you you can always drop on to
your knees and remember to breathe
throughout the entire workout alright
halfway there
strong core
whew your body shaking let's five more
last two and one okay very good
straight back up all right next sumo
squat we want to work more on your inner
thighs
all right so step white with a toast
point it out all right and now let's go
place the hands in front let's get down
push it out do the work on unifies three
four good five six seven eight nine ten
all right a little bit more challenge
get onto your toes okay get onto your
toes leave your shoes off let's go ten
more one two whoa I'm shaking three good
four five good it's also we're gonna
count six seven eight nine and ten
[Music]
okay back it down onto a plank
all right this time it's going to work
on your hips your Blix plank hip dip
okay let's go left and right left and
right tap left and right it's one two
good that's three as much as I can tap
your hips on to the floor nice and
remember to keep breathing pace your
breathing the better you are at pacing a
breathing the longer you will rush last
through the workout halfway there
breathe good remember to push your
shoulders away from your
breathe good okay last five more one two
three four and one more five all right
come back up okay let's mix it up a
little bit okay it's going to be a squat
to a lunch so I want you to maintain a
narrow position and stay low throughout
all right we'll be counting on the squat
not on the lunch all right let's go
one good sailor - okay nice a23
step back for five good six seven squat
low keep it narrow eight good nine ten
ten more squat little good one - white
step three drag your knees to the floor
four five six last four more guys view
the bread on your thigh seven eight nine
hahaha okay short plank with knee taps
alright so a slight different variation
what are we going to do is start on all
fours lift your knees about two inches
off the floor keeping in this position
just tap your knee okay so it's good to
work a lot on your core strength left
and right again is one so that's three
that's four five tap good remember do
not Pike your butt up
and good think about somewhere nice okay
not right here halfway there
ten more through the burn on your thighs
avoid moving your hips too much find
that strength good keep going that's
five more one two three ha for one more
okay
stay with me five all right come back up
okay
guess what we are already half way
through you have done it exercises all
right fall squats for planks now
another eight more exercises so let's
bring the heat up slightly okay I'm
already sweating
let's add in a little bit of explosive
movement so it's going to be squat jacks
all right so what are we to do is start
in a narrow squat position jump up tap
as you tap that's one
let's go one two push your butt back
three four good I know it's burning but
that's what we want to work on the
strength and endurance of our legs
halfway there
one two three tap four four push your
butt down three two one
okay still on the explosive movement one
more okay let's go plank jacks out and
in that's one two three good keep it up
bring up the speed halfway there
bring it up paste it out okay remember
do not like it but up and alright done
if you need to stretch it a little bit
let's get into a downward dog before we
continue
okay all right step forward okay short
break back to squats squats with Lake
race working on your outer hips all
right so stand shoulder with a pun
squat down left leg up squat down right
leg up okay so counting on the squats
push it really squeeze feel your hips
good squat down push it back make every
squat count up up
let's go halfway there that's ten more
one two three good four five that's five
or six seven last three more eight nine
and ten all right cross plank okay start
in a high plank position we want to
drive our right knee towards our left
elbow okay
and remember left and right is one so do
not rush through the workout feel the
work on your Blix and try to bring your
knee as far forward as you can you're
going right to left alternating good
we're halfway there let's go
eight more this is a really good total
body workout five more last three two
and one
all right oh okay all right get back up
we are not stopping right now let's stop
right at the end of this workout okay
it's going to be a narrow to wide squat
but we want to add double houses alright
so again stand with your feet together
one two okay
double houses so that's three that's
four five see I'm being nice fix good
pulse it seven stay low the whole goal
is to stay low eight nine had good
halfway there
say hello okay one two three four
good come on get down five six seven
push about that eight nine ten
okay all right get back down into a
plank a little bit more challenge on
your upper body plank up down all right
it's either you hit this or you love it
but whatever it is let's finish 20 reps
okay done
let's go counting on the down okay so
that's one two good strong core again
remember with all your planks do not dip
your hip left to right okay
strong arms push yourself up alternating
between the arms down do not just
collapse okay bring your arm down one at
a time all right happy day
keep filming your sweat is your fat
crying okay feel that heart rate of
yours down up few more that's three more
that's two more that's one more come
back up all right good news this is your
final squad workout and one last quad
one last leg and we are done
okay so step forward we want to again
bring the heat up slightly what I'm
going to do is start from the left side
of your mat and we want to lateral jump
to the right side of your mat so really
explosive movement really challenge your
legs
all right ready squat down up that's one
okay - good we're counting on the jump
three four five drive your hands forward
six seven without eight nine ten halfway
there okay let's go one two three four
use the momentum from your heads to help
you six seven eight nine that's one more
ten oh my gosh okay done on the squat
before I leave you one find a plank it's
going to be an isometric hold
so instead of a regular plank alright we
want to race one leg up and let's count
to 20 okay one two three four five six
no rushing to get anywhere nine ten one
two three
for brief 5 6 7 8 9 10 change left leg
down right leg up
come on tighten your core go 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 last time can you stay with me
ten nine eight seven holy six five four
three two and one
alright drop your knees get into a high
plank push back into downward facing dog
and just really push your heels into the
floor and lengthen and stretch out your
back if this is too difficult walk the
dog okay so raise your left and your
right heel off the mat one at a time
feel the stretch on your calves good
keep going walk it out
and now slowly come back down
Louie buddy down push up into a Cobra
and remember do not hunch
who's your shoulders away from your ears
and just look up and we want to bring
our heart rate back down
right and up who's just out back into a
child's pose and just stay here for
another 20 seconds okay very very well
done
so my challenge to you for the next 30
days is to complete this work out every
single day okay if you find that it's
too challenging and you can't finish the
entire workout that's okay stop it and
get back into the workout when you have
had enough rest if you find that you
can't do a full plank then start by
going on your knees and remove all the
jumps start with regular squats alright
my goal for you is to do this regularly
keep it consistent because you will only
get stronger okay you will only get
stronger on your entire body and your
core as well
so if you enjoy this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up like this video
share this video on tag your friends
challenge your friends to join you and
if you haven't yet subscribe to my
youtube channel then please go ahead and
subscribe okay I have a lot more crazy
workout challenges healthy recipes meal
plans workout plans everything to guide
you through your workout journey all the
best and I will see you next time